>>> NO TE WORD OADCASLE DUE TO E
COUNTRY.
THE THREAT OF ARS INR G TDIREAT
THUR IRELO L OPLE OW ABOUT WHA
>> THENT
YOSO I'M GLATO
THERE T
USSI  OET
BELIEVES THEPATE EVERYAY
VISIONS THAT RSI UNDERTH NATO H
SO ON AND SOTHER PARTN CIY, TV
VIEWERS E S
NDS WHICH T DAYSWAHAT AFTER WAS
ON VIEWS DAY
EO TE.IT MEANS THAT
F RUSSIANS WRSRRNDHO
UNT THEY NEECAUSEY FEEL
THAT A T
CATASTROPHE THAT HASS AND D
R THFOFOME D -MEAN,
ONS BUT HOW Y
AI
ISY  THED EST -- I WOULD EVEN R
GEORS, FBELL
IS
YOU CANNOT SAY I--NNCENTAGE,
AMSSOCIAA.GI Y
RT UNDERST
THINTHANOWDECIDE FORS.LO PEOPL O
AGKN, CAFROMIF EDO SUY HAVEHA RN
V T , KNOW COLLY  M
S ON
RA SG INISU
TELEOVERHIS
I DON'T KNOWM WHERE.UTIN
ARE THERPEOPLE WITHILE
Y U IMAGATE GE HISIES?
>> I TY BECAUSE WE
ABOUT IS UN
ALW IS THAT THER BR-C
IN THE GNM WF THE PREST,
OPND THIOPS
E N TERRITORIES BACK, TO BUILPIE
'TAN THESE  A ISALWH
ARE NOHAROOPLE WCHANGE SITUATIO
E DERIGHT ING R ER EUROPPANEOPLE
OF FREEDOMS INA, A BE FLEXIBLE.N
TH VLADIMIR PUTIN, HAS KILL
IT WAS NOT -IT A REKNOWOF COURSS
SSSEENKE
AN THAT SOON, BUDON'T KN R ES R
THAT THIS COULD BE THE PUTIN INE
ANI REALLY
WHAT'S GOIN IE INOFTHE  I
NOT ALONE HERE OUT
COUNTRY.NG
JO, MYND
READY TFIE SIA.
THE TRUTH.IS- TH
WTHRE ACT